notre invité politique ce matin c'est
elisabeth moreno bonjour bonjour à tous
avec nos ministre déléguée chargée de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
de la diversité et de l'égalité des
chances
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale bonjour
pascal jalabert du groupe ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
on a beaucoup de sujets d'actualité à
voir avec vous elisabeth moreno et on va
commencer par mérignac et ce féminicide
qui a ému qui a choqué qu'ils posent
aussi des questions
cette jeune femme qui a été brûlée vive
par son ancien compagnon alors qu'elle
avait porté plainte alors qu'il avait
fait de la prison pour violences
conjugales
il ya une mission d'inspection qui a été
lancé par le ministère de l'intérieur et
par le garde des sceaux elle pointait
une série de défaillances dans le suivi
de ce conjoint le rapport final sera
rendu le 10 juin mais est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus sur les
défaillances quelles sont-elles c'est la
police et la justice c'est toute une
chaîne chahinez et est maman d'une de
trois enfants qui sont aujourd'hui
orphelins et je veux rappeler combien
ces féminicide ne touche pas que les
femmes qui sont concernées mais c'est
toute une société qui est en émoi quand
ce genre de choses arrive et moi j'ai
été absolument horrifiés et je peux vous
dire que ça a été une nuit très
difficile ce jour-là est évidemment la
première question qu'on se pose c'est
comment se fait-il qu après tout ce qui
a été mis en place depuis ces trois
dernières années notamment les 46
mesures du grenelle sur lesquelles nous
nous sommes battus avec les associations
au quotidien on en arrive encore à ce
genre de situation les bracelets
anti-rapprochement ont été déployés les
ordonnances de déploiement ont été
démultipliés les téléphones grave danger
ont été démultipliés les policiers ont
été formés les magistrats sont
complètement mobilisés sur ces questions
comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là la
première chose qui s'est passé c'est que
lorsque cet assassin a été condamné pour
ces violences il a été enfermé et puis
il est sorti de prison il se trouve qu'à
ce moment là les bracelets anti
rapprochement n'était pas encore mise en
oeuvre puisqu'ils ont été déployés dans
toutes les juridictions françaises à la
fin de
l'année dernière et évidemment le
ministère de l'intérieur ainsi que le
garde des sceaux ont décidé de
diligenter cette enquête pour comprendre
où étaient les défaillances moi je peux
vous dire que aujourd'hui on peut être
plutôt heureux d'une chose c'est que
l'on constate dans notre pays que les
féminicides baisse et qu'ils baissent de
manière importante puisque pour la
première fois nous sommes aux alentours
d'une centaine de femmes et chaque
féminicide reste un féminisme
inacceptable mais ça veut dire quand
même que les dispositifs fonctionnent
est ce qu'il faut aller plus vite plus
loin et ce qu'il faut accélérer
c'est exactement le sens du mai de
l'appel que j'ai lancé au magistrat pour
leur dit on va y venir bien sûr mais
dans la sphère chahinez quels ont été
les défaillants alors écoutez je ne peux
pas encore vous voulez donner en détail
dans la mesure où nous allons
communiquer les premières les premiers
résultats ont été communiqués la semaine
dernière mais il faut encore aller plus
loin pour comprendre où il y a eu dans
les différentes étapes pourquoi ce
monsieur n'a pas pu être trouvé plus
rapidement pourquoi est-ce qu'il avait
une arme ça on le sait par exemple parce
que aujourd'hui la saisie des armes se
fait dans les appartements dans les
foyers et il se trouve que ces armes
étaient non seulement pas déclarés mais
qu'elle était dans des les différents
véhicules dont il disposait donc encore
une fois je le dis et j'insiste même si
ça peut être difficile à entendre parce
que au bout du compte une personne est
décédée
mais les dispositifs aujourd'hui sont en
place aujourd'hui il fonctionne c'est ce
que les associations nous disent et ce
qu'ils font à leon van bon jour là et là
en l'occurrence ils n'ont pas fonctionné
donc le 10 juin prochain
nous communiquerons officiellement sur
tout ce qui a pu dysfonctionné et
surtout nous allons voir ce qu'il faut
mettre en place pour que ça fonctionne
beaucoup mieux et que ce genre de
situation nous saurons vous expliquer
qu'en espagne a pris trop grand ni fait
station est en train de mesures ils y
soient arrivés très vite et qu en france
on n'y arrive pas alors comment fait
plus alors on ne peut pas dire qu'en
france on n'y arrive pas vous savez j'ai
échangé avec mon homologue parce que
l'espagne vous avez raison de le
mentionner est le pays le plus
emblématique sur c'est sûr sur ces
questions puisqu'ils ont commencé dès
2003 nous nous avons commencé en 2010
est donc ça fait quand même une
différence il a fallu attendre
que ce soit la grande cause du
quinquennat pour qu'enfin nous ayons ce
grenelle des violences conjugales qui a
embarqué 15 ministres parce que vous
imaginez bien que c'est travail
c'est un travail interministériel qui
doit être fait et mon homologue espagnol
me disait que le décollage des bracelets
entier rapprochement avait pris trois
ans donc dans les premiers mois ça a été
50 ensuite ils sont passés à 80 ensuite
ils sont passés à 150
nous nous en sommes à six mois de mise
en oeuvre de cet outil et n'avait qu'un
chiffre assez édifiant quant à miami le
bracelet anti rapprochement existants il
y en a seulement 45 voilà sont utilisés
qu elle allait financer un peu plus il y
aura sur 110 16
il y en a 76 et c'est aussi la raison
pour laquelle eric dupond moretti a
indiqué qu'il allait lancer à nouveau
une circulaire pour rappeler que ces
bracelets doivent être absolument
utiliser par par les magistrats
maintenant vous savez pourquoi pas le
travail et ils ne s'en servent pas
pourquoi je ne veux pas qu'ils ne s'en
servent pas je dirais surtout à l'instar
de quelques jeunes magistrats que j'ai
pu rencontrer sur le terrain comme
monsieur morel le quai le magistrat de
nîmes qui est très engagé sur ces
questions de violence parce que je veux
le dire il y à des magistrats qui était
déjà engagé sur ces questions de
violence bien avant et d'autres qui sont
en train de prendre en considération ces
niveaux dispositif mais encore une fois
admettons que ça ne fait que six mois
que ces bracelets ont été mis en oeuvre
et que maintenant il faut absolument
accélérer le processus et qu'il faut
continuer de saisir les armes et qu'il
faut de plus en plus de téléphones grave
danger distribués pour que ces femmes se
sentent davantage en sécurité
il faut continuer de travailler et c'est
toute la société qui doit se saisir de
ces questions je ne le dirai jamais
assez
quand une maîtresse voit une maman
déposer son enfant à l'école
trois jours de suite avec un oeil au
beurre noir et qu'à chaque fois elle dit
qu'elle s'est pris une porte non à un
moment donné il ya quelque chose qui
dysfonctionnent quand des voisins
entendent une femme qui se fait tabasser
et qui disent non c'est pas mes affaires
c'est parce que c'est de la sphère
privée
non ça n'est pas vrai parce qu'on peut
sauver des vies en dénonçant ces
agressions parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons encore deux cent vingt mille
femmes qui disent être victimes de
violence sans parler de celles qui ne le
sont pas
je veux dire à ces femmes que nous
sommes là qu avec les associations nous
les écouterons nous les accompagnerons
et qu'il faut continuer de déposer
plainte et ne pas prendre un seul cas
pour dire que tout ce processus
extrêmement important qui a été mis en
place ne fonctionne pas parce que c'est
faux ça fonctionne dans la plupart des
temps et il y a des cas malheureusement
comme celui là qui nous rappelle que le
travail est encore extrêmement importé
justement pour éviter qu'ils aient
d'autres cas qui se produit sous nous
dit donc le 10 juin on aura les
conclusions de la mission d'information
vous allez prendre des mesures
supplémentaires qu'est ce qu'il y aura
une nouvelle loi de nouvelles mesures ou
est ce que vous allez faire en sorte que
les mesures existantes soient appliquées
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ne s'agit
plus d'accumuler les lois vous savez il
ya eu trois lois qui ont été votées dans
ce gouvernement pour protéger les
victimes
donc accumulé les lois si elles ne sont
pas mises en oeuvre si elles ne sont pas
exécutées ça ne sert à rien aux fins de
la loi ne suffit pas il faut maintenant
on est rentré dans un changement de
mentalité dans un changement de culture
extrêmement important il y à une
nécessité de continuer à sensibiliser
continuer à informer le 39 19 d'ici la
fin du mois de juin qui est la ligne qui
accueille la parole des femmes victimes
de violence va être accessible 7 jours
sur 7 24 heures sur 24 aux femmes en
situation de handicap aux femmes
aphasique
il faut que le 114 soit de plus en plus
connu il faut que la plateforme arrêtons
les violences point gouv.fr soit plus
connue il faut que nous continuons de
déployer aussi des centres de prise en
charge des auteurs parce que jusque-là
on s'était occupé des victimes mais on
n'avait pas mis en place des structures
pour accompagner psychologiquement
physiquement mentalement à la
réinsertion professionnelle de toutes
ces personnes
et c'est un travail extrêmement
important que nous sommes en train de
mener
ne négligeons pas la taille de l'enjeu
qui est devant nous et travailleuses et
un traitement ça serait une meilleure
application des mesures actuelles ait
pas de nouvelles mesures absolument sont
annoncés on va parler de la journée
internationale contre l'homophobie
puisque c'est aujourd'hui pascal oui
c'est aujourd'hui donc journée nationale
contre
phobies et toutes les discriminations à
l'égard des personnes dites lgbt
comment la france va décliner cette
mesure et puis prendre faut-il prendre
encore des des mesures contre les
discriminations cv en 2019 et il y avait
pas moins de 2000 personnes qui est
lesbienne gay bi trans qui disait avoir
été agressé physiquement dans la rue du
fait de leur orientation sexuelle ou de
leur identité de genre
même si ces chiffres ont baissé en 2020
moi je ne peux pas me satisfaire de cela
parce qu'il y avait énormément de gens
aujourd'hui qui continue de souffrir du
fait de leur orientation sexuelle du
fait de qui elles sont deux du fait de
qui elle aime et je me réjouis qu'il y
ait cette journée mondiale de lutte
contre l'homophobie la biphobie et la
transphobie pourquoi c'est important et
pourquoi ça arrive au niveau
international parce qu'aujourd'hui
encore en 2021 dans certains pays
lorsque vous êtes homosexuel lorsque
vous êtes bisexuelle et bien vous pouvez
être condamné à mort vous pouvez être
condamnée à être en prison il se trouve
qu'en europe et en france en particulier
depuis de nombreuses années depuis les
années 80 il ya eu énormément de progrès
qui ont été faits mais on se rend encore
compte qu'il ya beaucoup de
discrimination envers les personnes lgbt
plus et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
14 octobre dernier nous avons lancé un
plan national en faveur des droits et de
la lutte contre la haine et les
discriminations envers les personnes
lgbt plus l'objectif de ce plan c'est de
faire en sorte que leurs droits soient
reconnus parce que ils ont ils et elles
ont des droits aujourd'hui mais qui ne
sont pas encore complètement reconnu je
vous donne un exemple depuis sept ans
maintenant les couples
homosexuels ont la possibilité d'adopter
mais on se rende compte qu'il y ait un
nombre infime de couples qui sont encore
arrivés
il s'agit aussi de s'assurer que leurs
droits soient véritablement respecter
parce que ne serait ce que dans le monde
de l'emploi
il y encore très peu de peu de personnes
lesbiennes gays bi ou trans qui peuvent
bénéficier des droits dans l'entreprise
parce qu'ils n'osent pas dire qu'ils
sont lesbiennes il n'ose pas donné le
nom de leurs partenaires qui est une
femme dans un couple de femmes - hommes
dans un couple d'hommes donc il faut que
ces droits soient également davantage
mise en avant que l'on puisse utiliser
son prénom d'usagé comme l'enseignement
supérieur l'a fait pour une personne qui
est en parcours de transition ce sont
ces gestes là qui font que vous pouvez
être qui vous êtes et que vous puissiez
vivre votre vie indépendamment de votre
orientation sexuelle parce que ça
n'enlève aucun endroit à personne mais
ça permet à des personnes de mieux vivre
et jeu juste vous rappeler que les
insultes les plus récurrentes dans les
cours d'école ou dans les stades
aujourd'hui ça reste
donc c'est vous dire c'est l'agression
que ces personnes là vivent au quotidien
et c'est bien qu'il y ait cette journée
internationale et je me réjouis
d'ailleurs nous avons signé avec 14 pays
européens
une tribune qui va paraître en fin de
matinée dans le monde je crois
quatorze pays européens qui répondent à
ces agressions qui arrivent aussi en
europe parce que vous avez entendu
parler de la décision de la pologne
d'avoir des zones lgbt freezone 100
personnes lgbt
qu'est ce que ça signifie qu'est ce que
ça signifie que ce genre d'attitude
donc il est important ensemble que nous
continuons de lutter en faveur des
droits des personnes lgbt plus parce que
ce sont des citoyens et des citoyennes à
part entière et que nous devons la
france se doit non seulement au niveau
national mais aussi au niveau
international de défendre les droits des
personnes lesbiennes gaies bi et trans
et questions sur les thérapies de
conversion et les abattements et nous
avait annoncé une circulaire pour
appeler l'arsenal législatif contre
cette thérapie de conversion qui sera
publiée qu'en cette circulaire alors
c'est tuer
le garde des sceaux est en train de
travailler dessus mais il va aller très
très vite alors je n'ai pas annoncé unsa
sur la vie de ces camps jeu dans les
jours qui viennent je vous promets de
vous communiquer la date rapidement
parce que c'est un sujet extrêmement
important mais vous savez j'ai j'ai
répondu à une question qui lui était
posée à l'assemblée nationale il y a
quelques jours et j'ai vu l'émotion qui
est on ait surgi de la part des
associations qui travaillent depuis
tellement longtemps sur ces questions
avec laurence 25 blog que je veux saluer
parce que depuis trois ans elle porte
avec courage des débats des discussions
elle a une proposition de loi qu'elle a
présentée et que nous allons je l'espère
inscrire bientôt dans les débats mais ça
ne s'est pas fait encore ce n'est en
position pour le moment l effet le
calendrier ça n'est pas encore fait mais
vous savez dès le premier jour dès que
j'ai commencé à rencontrer les
différentes associations qui luttent
contre ces thérapies dites de conversion
parce qu'il faut mal comprendre le sujet
de l'homophobie pour de de
l'homosexualité pardon pour croire qu'on
peut transformer des personnes alors
même qu'elles sont parfaites telles
qu'elles sont et qu'il n'ya rien
absolument rien n'a guérir donc ces
thérapies de conversion sont strictement
interdites en france
je les dis et je le répète j'ai toujours
autant de volonté de me battre contre
ces thérapies de conversion pourquoi
nous avons dit qu'il fallait rappeler
les lois c'est parce que dans notre pays
il rit il existe déjà un arsenal
juridique pour protéger les personnes
qui subissent ces agressions et il faut
bien sûr qu'il faut aller plus loin et à
la drm loi une loi à proprement parler
vers ce sujet oui ce que souhaite
laurens van den broeck et je comprends
cette demande c'est qu'il y ait une
pénalité spécifique ou
ou des sanctions spécifiques sur ce
genre d'agression qui encore une fois je
le précise interdit par la loi et nous
avons dit qu'il fallait rappeler la loi
parce que beaucoup d'associations disent
que ces lois ne sont pas connues
qu'elles ne sont pas appliquées donc
nous avons décidé avec le garde des
sceaux
en attendant que cette loi puisse voir
le jour de rappeler les dispositifs qui
légaux qui existent pour que les
personnes puissent saisir ces dix mois
parce que c'est une députée de la
majorité pourquoi cette loi n'est pas
inscrite du coup dans le calendrier
parlementaire vous savez il y a
malheureusement beaucoup de choses qui
étaient en ligne de marche et qui n'ont
qui ont été freinés par la crise
sanitaire et il y a eu une actualité
extrêmement importante à l'assemblée
nationale ça doit faire partie des
urgences est planté je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement important
que nous devons continuer de porter avec
beaucoup de volontarisme parce que ce
sont des atteintes à la dignité et à
l'intégrité humaine qui sont totalement
inacceptables et intolérables dans notre
pays on va parler d'une autre loi qui
celle-ci a été inscrite a été adoptée
c'est la proposition de loi rixin
castaner pour aller
de manière simple elle impose la parité
dans les postes de direction c'est un
peu la suite de la loi copé zimmermann
qui imposait la parité dans les conseils
d'administration est ce que c'est quand
même pas un échec pour les femmes de
devoir passer par une loi et par des
quotas pour avoir la parité est ce que
c'est un échec pour les femmes
est ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
aucune femme n'aime être recruté parce
qu'elle est un quota aucune
les femmes aiment à être recruté parce
qu'elles sont compétentes
parce qu'elles sont capables parce
qu'elles ont des ambitions parce
qu'elles ont envie d'apporter leur
valeur ajoutée et il y a pléthore
d'études qui ont été montrées s'il était
nécessaire que les entreprises les plus
diverses étaient les plus performants et
les plus durables les plus résilientes
les plus créatives et cetera et cetera
sauf qu'aujourd'hui les lois vous
rajoutez des quotas eh bien pourquoi on
en est encore là la raison pour laquelle
nous en sommes encore à une situation où
il faut légiférer c'est d'abord parce
qu'on s'est rendu compte que la loi copé
zimmermann a fonctionné la loi copé
zimmermann qui a été votée en 2010 eh
bien nous a fait passer de 9 % de femmes
dans les conseils d'administration à 45
% en seulement dix ans seulement dix ans
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui pour
les femmes dans la sphère
professionnelle
les femmes ont les métiers les plus
précaires elles ont les métiers les
moins reconnu les moins payés entre 9 et
25 % d'écart salarial entre les femmes
et les hommes 9 % quand bien même vous
avez les mêmes compétences la même
expérience et le même job qui est la
première loi en faveur de l'égalité
salariale date de 1972 1972 on est en
2021 et on a encore des écarts de
salaires extrêmement important on a
encore 43 % de nos entreprises qui ont
entre 0 et une seule femme dans leurs
postes de cadres dirigeants ou de comex
codir alors pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
légiférer il faut légiférer parce que
sur ces questions là
progression est extrêmement lente parce
que depuis le mois de janvier 2021 et
maintenant il y a eu six nominations de
postes stratégiques dans des grands
groupes le dernier étant danone 6 et
qu'il n'y a eu aucune femme de nommer
pourquoi est ce qu'il faut légiférer
parce que c'est une manière de
d'accélérer le processus
parce que comme le dit le world economic
forum si on attend et si on ne bouge pas
et bien et ça nous prendra encore deux
cent cinquante sept ans mais l'arrivée a
évoqué que des hommes se sentent floués
en disant à écouter j'avais peut-être
autant voire plus de mérite que cet
homme est au nom d'un quota me passe de
langue nous n'avons strictement jamais
demandé à ce que des femmes passe devant
en étant incapable et incompétente
nous demandons juste dans ce cas là je
peux vous dire les femmes peuvent être
en situation de dire moi aussi je suis
flou et parce que je suis capable et
compétente et on ne me donne pas la
chance de pouvoir exprimer mais comment
mon expression
oui mais alors dans ce cas là
aujourd'hui on n'a que 30 % de femmes à
peine 30 % de femmes dans les postes de
cadres dire il ne faut pas rêver par
exemple je vous donne un exemple le
concours de l'école des mines ça fait
des années que ce sont les hommes qui
l'ont et par fo avaient paraphé comment
les candidatures vous avez chaud pour
avoir les critères scolaires et d'autres
choses alors vous avez tout à fait
raison et ça me donne l'occasion parce
que tout le monde s'émeut de cette
question d'objectifs chiffrés et de
quotas mais cette loi va bien plus loin
que ça et vraiment je veux saluer le
travail extraordinaire que marie-pierre
x1 et christophe castaner ont fait parce
que cette loi a quand même été voté à
l'unanimité un l'unanimité mercredi
dernier je veux rappeler que cette loi
ça n'est pas qu'une loi sur les quotas
c'est une loi qui fait en sorte aussi
que les femmes qui sont sous emprise
aujourd'hui de leurs conjoints qui
travaillent qui touche un salaire mais
le salaire va sur le compte du conjoint
est le conjoint ne donne qu au compte
gouttes comme il le souhaite
à
la femme qui travaille cet argent c'est
inacceptable on s en 2021
vous vous rendez compte juste pour
avancer là dessus parce que c'est
vraiment important vous avez mentionné
la question des du vivier c'est pour ça
aussi qu'il y a dans cette loi une
demande à l'enseignement supérieur
d'avoir aussi davantage de filles dans
les filières où aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas suffisamment de filles je pense au
numérique
je pense au btp je pense à
l'aéronautique je pense à l'automobile
qui dit on dit toujours aux femmes
vous ne pouvez pas aller dans le btp
parce que vous ne pourrez pas porter un
sac de ciment
mais quand les femmes sont dans les
ehpad et qu'elle porte des personnes de
82 cents kilos là on ne leur reproche
pas donc il faut qu'on soit un peu
cohérent
moi je crois que c'est une question de
justice sociale et je me réjouie
qu'enfin notre pays donne la tonalité là
dessus je veux juste rappeler qu'on est
les premiers en europe 1 etc on doit
être fier on est les pays de droits de
l'homme et les pays de droits de l'homme
c'est aussi les pays des droits et sur
l'actualité est ce que vous regrettez le
choc danone qui a donc choisi un homme
pour succéder à emmanuel faber alors
qu'une femme était en lice
je pense que d'abord je ne dois pas
commenter les choix de danone loin de
moi cette idée
moi ce que je demande aux entreprises
c'est de considérer les candidatures
capable et compétente de toutes les
femmes et c'est l'intention de cette loi
et j'espère que dans les années qui
viendront nous ne continuerons pas dire
qu'en 2021
nous avons une seule femme qui dirige un
grand groupe du cac 40 et 4 femmes
seulement dans les 120 plus grandes
entreprises de france la justice elle
est véritablement à ce niveau là et
c'est catherine mcgregor qui dirige
angie on va la cité puisque
effectivement elle est la seule question
aussi autour de gisèle halimi de la
panthéonisation disait la limite puisque
désormais des questions se posent autour
de sa pinte sa panthéonisation selon
france inter emmanuel mâcon pour y
renoncer en raison de ses prises de
position pendant la guerre d'algérie
est ce que vous confirmez ces
informations est ce que vous confirmez
que le président de la république
pourrait renoncer à cette mentonnaise
alors je voudrais juste quand même
rappeler que le président de la
république n'avait pris aucun engagement
sur ce sur cette question nous moi moi
je fais partie des personnes extrêmement
volontaire sur cette question mais je
suis ministre en charge de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes
gisèle halimi fait partie de ces femmes
extrêmement engagée sur la cause des
femmes elle
il est également que les femmes pour
obtenir leur liberté devrait obtenir
leur meilleur émancipation économique
elle s'est battu toute sa vie elle a
défendu contre vents et marées les 343
et cetera et c'est toute sa vie
elle s'est battue pour les femmes elle a
fait en sorte que la situation des
femmes dans notre pays progresse elle a
progressé et c'est à ce titre là que
j'ai demandé sa panthéonisation mais le
président de la république n'a jamais en
tout cas pas que je sache il n'a pas
pris d'engagement sur cette question
mais ça va faire ou pas à je ne sais pas
je vais pas dans jean macé et non je
n'ai pas d'information là-dessus alors
d'autres suntory que joséphine baker qui
est aussi un emblème pour beaucoup de
français soit portée aux nous et vous
fait plaisir à mes oreilles ce matin
parce que gisèle halimi joséphine baker
ce sont des femmes pour qui j'ai
immensément de respect et de
considération vis de leurs engagements
ils pour l'entrée de joséphine baker au
panthéon vous avez vous la sonorisation
évidemment jeu là c'est une femme
admirable engagé qui croyaient dans les
valeurs de l'universalisme à 2,20 moi je
jouis je l'admiré évidemment dernière
avant dernière question il n'y aurait
une question de pascal à la fin puisque
vous avez signé hier dans le journal du
dimanche une tribune avec caroline
fourest pour la pma pour toutes
pourquoi cette tribune ça veut dire que
le combat n'est pas gagné pour vous
alors d'abord j'ai signé cette tribune
avec caroline fourest avec larry cette
bd nous avec marie clémence bordés
nicaise avec xavier pavie avec marinette
pichon je veux les mentionner parce que
vous savez les personnes qui s'engagent
alors qu'elles ne sont pas obligés de le
faire
mérite qu'on mette leur nom sur le
devant de la scène parce que si nous
avions plus de personnes engagées
je pense que notre pays serait plus
juste et plus inclusif
cette tribune nous l'avons signé
simplement parce que je crois que la pma
vous savez et il y à une rupture
d'égalité entre les femmes qui sont dans
les couples hétérosexuels aujourd'hui et
les femmes dans les couples lesbiens et
dans les couples et les femmes
célibataire pourquoi certaines femmes
dans notre pays pourrait avoir accès à
la pma et d'autres pas et cette
inégalité est cette loi est au parlement
et c'est une façon de dire qu' il ne
faut pas l'oublier que c'est important
qu'il faut continuer d'en parler qu'il
faut expliquer pourquoi c'est important
est que la majorité présidentielle je
veux juste être certaines qu'elles ne
soient pas où vous avez un doute et je
non j'ai aucun doute vous avez olivier
ferrand a dit que le premier bébé naîtra
d'ici la fin de l'année
j'y crois et c'est pour ça que je suis
heureuse d'avoir signé cet cette tribune
et je crois qu'il faut encore faire de
la pédagogie sur cette question parce
que de nombreuses personnes manifestent
leur leur avis opposé et je pense que si
elle comprenait véritablement ceux dont
on parle
eh bien elle serait beaucoup plus
favorable et dernière question parmi
elles la liste j'aurais été dans
l'hérault compte et une femme portant le
voile islamique
comment vous réagissez à sa stanislas
guérini le patron de la f1 on va retirer
l'investiture
vous êtes d'accord avec lui alors
stanislas guérini et le patron du dollar
m il prend les décisions qui s'imposent
en tant que patron de l'ars m moi je dis
que aujourd'hui que je sache je pense
que l'erreur principale que stanislas
aurait pu commettre c'est ces deux de
travailler sur l'injonction de du front
national moi c'est c'est vraiment ce qui
m'a touché après les des larges avenues
un problème de méthode
sur le fond il a sur le fond il a eu des
gens fait et je connais les valeurs de
son existence et je pense sur le fond
moi je dis que d'abord vous savez ça me
je trouve que nous parlons beaucoup de
ce sujet là alors ce que ce qui est
véritablement important c'est qu'est ce
que nous faisons justement sur le fond
non mais ça dissuade de la majorité est
ce que
les diviser la majorité sur ce sur ce
point de quel côté êtes-vous est-ce
qu'il fallait ou pas en tirer
l'investiture
ça ne ce n'est pas à moi de décider
stanislas a pris sa décision ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que la loi vous
qu'est une femme voilée sur une affiche
électorale de la république en marche
la loi ne l'interdisait pas maintenant
d'un point de vue marketing
communication que de stanislas et
décider cela moi j'ai vu le parti
socialiste le faire en son temps j'ai vu
martine aubry le faire j'ai vu donc
voilà recentrons nous sur ce qui est
véritablement important
merci beaucoup merci vous avez demandé
ce matin merci parce qu'elle a une des
dernières nouvelles d'alsace et du foot
ou et laissez-la lourd
le maintien n'est pas assuré mais quand
même en bonne voie pour strasbourg il
fallait à tout prix gagner ce match ils
l'ont fait et voilà et suite dernière
journée dimanche merci beaucoup merci
d'une phase 2
[Musique]